[Music]
so we're here with Jilly Barlow who's a
good friend of mine also a successful
property investor and just a great
person so welcome to the show Jilly
thank you very much Sam it's great to be
here and what now you're doing some
training with our guys and they're
absolutely loving it why don't you just
give us a little bit of background in a
nutshell what is it that you do in
property and what's your background okay
so I'm an identical twin I came out of
school at 16 with nothing to be proud of
and had grown up really believing I was
rubbish to everything but due to my
faith at a young age I had always
believed that I was something but I just
had nothing to show for it I ended up
setting up a little business and
bizarrely enough at a very young age
ended up flying to Africa where I
believed that I was molded you know so
much happened so many experiences
animals related people related all sorts
related I learnt to fly but all sorts of
things went on that really I think made
me a large part of who I am today
that's incredible and you're you talk a
lot about your faith you talked a lot
about purpose and you love charities and
different dislike which is which is
absolutely fantastic so we relate on
that level where does money and buying
properties and all that where does that
fit in to to that I'm very it's a very
interesting question that because I
think that when you go along your
journey it takes a while to a discover
who you are truly but also discover what
your gifts and purposes are but I I
believe I know mine and it's through my
experiences and my reading and my
learning and my faith that I've
discovered what that is I'm sure there's
more to it than I'm about to say but for
me it's about building people up so I
don't know if you've known or heard of
love languages many people have many
people have my top love languages words
and I can understand and relate to how
that is in that I've spent all my life
really building people up and having and
helping them to see that they're
precious but I didn't realize I was
doing that but the
negative side of that is that you get
crushed by words as well so you have to
learn in this world to to not take it on
the chin but to actually try and more
work to try and understand where the
person's come from themselves that's
made them say it but words are really
really massive in this world
in actual fact Samuel I've just finished
all doing my first book and that book
grows roses
thank you and that book was meant to be
on property I mentioned property once
what it is is about understanding
contentment and that contentment needs
to come first
many many people do it the wrong way
around so I want to can I give you a
picture yes if I say imagine a tire
rolling down a hill okay but this time
we're going to look at it as being a
gold coin many people chase after it
it's on a hill so it's quite difficult
to catch it and many catch it but
there's so much momentum there that it's
exhausting hanging onto it so they let
go of it again and then they catch it
again and then they let go over it again
and they're constantly chasing more and
more other people grab hold of it and
with all their might they hang onto it
but they don't know what living is all
about they never see their families they
never go away because they're the the
businessman that stressed out to the max
and is just working all their lives to
hold on to that money then there's the
other people of course who never catch
it and deem themselves hopeless and it's
very very sad
and I think that what's happening is
people assuming have you ever heard
someone say if I could just get that
house or just go on that holiday it'll
be all right yeah and what they're doing
is they're making something in the
future they'll reason for their
happiness yeah and what often happens I
don't know if you find this is that they
get there and the boundaries move
exactly and so how many people really
truly know contentment and I think the
big thing for me is trying to help
people understand what success is
success is often just about money but
it's not about money money believe you
me I understand may have a part
because of the environment because of
the the place we live our society we do
need money to live but the point is it
isn't everything and if I said to you
what do you think success is what would
you say some you I would say success is
having a good life some sex is having a
goal run hit in it success is different
for different people right I agree I
would say success is a good life but
where things are different for different
people is your idea of a good life might
not be my idea of a good life but it is
a good life and I give this descript
this example if you had a couple living
in a tent massively happy nothing
materialistic they understand love and
then you've got the billionaire who's
about to hang himself who's successful
well hit the billionaire successful
financially but then he's not balanced
he's not he's not successful and also
I've seen no success there at all if
they got to a point where they want to
live then their lives
no so tell me then I totally agree with
that
and sometimes the main thing is that the
main thing stays the main thing and
people want money for a purpose to
achieve an objective but sometimes we
forget about the objective in the first
place and we just continually chase more
money more money more money but of
course like a currency a number on a
bank isn't actually going to make you
happy which is which is really true so
really good points there what success
have you had in property because I know
you are a person of success you do have
money so tell me a bit about that the
property for me has been monumental it's
grown me significantly as a person and
because of the contentment first of all
there's been an element of success I
have made mistakes and I've grown from
them again it's all about attitude so
for me a large part of my success has
come from lightbulb moment or light bulb
moments where I suddenly realized it was
all about me in terms of my mindset
mindset is absolutely key and due to my
understanding of that and growing and
learning more and more
about it I have managed to achieve goals
that I've set they've moved because they
do when situations as life change and
values change but I've loved it and I
came from a place Samuel where I had no
money no ability to get a mortgage and
actually no support outside of the
environment that I found myself in
afterwards and I therefore used a
strategy called options but people also
get very confused when you talk about
strategy I might say to a person what's
your strategy and they say options I
said well no that that is a way of
acquiring a property but then what
you're going to do with it
so I see very clear guide columns of
strategy type so acquiring a property or
you have one lots of strategy so it
might be purchase it might be options it
might be rent to rent it might be
delayed completion it might be an
installment contract and so on strategy
in terms of what you're going to do with
the project might be HMO it might be
flip it might be serviced accommodation
it might be a number of different things
so I started acquiring the properties as
options because I in my we chose that we
didn't have any money but absolutely in
my view I had no other option and you
were able to secure properties using
options using no money no money that's
incredible that's incredible what a lot
of people think that sounds too good to
be true even though watch this right now
you started no money no support no
nothing
and then you acquired a bunch of
properties with an option agreement
attitude yeah I'm sorry to come back to
it but attitude and mindset is a lot to
do with it
I love options and I believe that there
are only two reasons people don't
options one is they think they can't
find them so they don't and two is they
find them and everybody they speak to
runs off to the hills because all the
words that come out of their mouths are
wrong is words something is words if you
come from a place that the other people
are at and you remember it's about
them and their scenario their situation
their motivation their pain if you go in
wanting to help and if you speak words
that are about those people for those
people rather than always for you it
doesn't matter whether you're speaking
to the vendor the agent whether it's to
do with a JV partner or maybe even an
investor if you want to put a little bit
of money into it you've got to come from
where they're at so true so true some
words on massive yeah so yeah that's
what I started with yeah like I said the
crash course for me when I say you need
to know the magic words but then at the
same time it's also that where you're
coming from if you're coming from a
position of deal then you're gonna scare
them away because of your attitude
beause if you come from the position of
use the right words and you come from
the position of actually trying to help
them yeah and what's best for this
person actually I think the options best
for them and then you and then you
present it in a certain why you're going
to get the deal yep so incredible then
what happened then so you're how many
partners did you do on a lease option
agreement um
not many because I tend to go quite big
so I do love big property so my very
first option was a six bedroom date you
know with a one-bedroom Bannock and you
don't need many of those no and because
I then went on to sort of small Hotel
East right stroke a guest houses which
sort of generates
sort of between twenty and thirty
thousand pounds a month I did I don't
need lots of them I don't want lots of
them to be perfectly honest yeah and the
first one I found of that size I did is
an option do you believe that you can
retire from one deal of course it
depends what that deal is yeah but you
can you can do then you can do that deal
with using none of your own moment yeah
100% and you've got the right mindset
mindset is key what's the best deal that
you've ever got Wow well um I would say
the best deals deals I've got which is
what you asked me would be my hotels
because I love that intelligence was ran
as a serviced accommodation well yes and
no staff well the first one still got a
little bit of stock but we are weeding
them out the second one none
you're gonna scare people off when you
say serviced accommodations in hotels
because people think there's so much
work I mean people think single let's
easy HMOs a bit difficult service
accommodation nightmare but that's not
the case is it it's not the case and
again it's mindset but also its truth
yeah okay there are many people out
there that will convince you you can't
do it you shouldn't do it and if you do
do it they need to do it on your behalf
you can do it it's all about systems
it's all now I am NOT a systems person I
absolutely love the systems resulting in
great results for service accommodation
they are so easy to use and the thing is
I believe that they are more passive I
believe the service commendations are
properties I've got a more passive than
my HMOs the only reason I continue to do
a few HMOs is because I allow them to go
out to other people as rent to rents so
all my HMOs be their options or now
purchased I give to other charities or
individuals from my meetings and they
take them as a five year rent to rent so
I have nothing to do that was really
interesting and because there's enough
profit in the deal for more than one
person to win of course there you're
saying I just want a guaranteed rent
I'll pass it on I'll let the next person
make a few hundred pounds a month and
then be responsible which is really
interesting because I do though some of
my properties as well it's really funny
because I took my property actually
quite recently a 6 bed picture now which
I passed on to somebody like that I
passed that Ellen as a rent to rent I'd
rather just have a guaranteed income and
I just thought it'd be better that way
but then I remember thinking 10 years
ago I'd love to have been that person
who's there I'm know they're going to
make about six hundred pounds a month
profit and then invested very little
money so it's just win winning it's
about finding where you're at right now
and you're in your life and then working
with people that it is but ten years ago
you're absolutely right but ten years
ago summer you were probably in a
situation or position where you wanted
that income and you're willing to do an
element of work for it now you're in a
position where due to your dynamic and
your values you'd probably not choose
to do that work but just to do choose to
do what makes you thrive and Rob them
where you can be passionate have passion
she's not managing HIV yes and so now
you're able to have a journey which is
conducive to what your calling is and
what your purpose is and allowed the
other person to make the money when we
start out we do what we can don't we
yeah and I was the same I was looking
after ex-prisoners in houses but it
wasn't conducive of my journey because I
wasn't I wasn't educated or I didn't
have degrees in looking after people and
psychology and what-have-you and I
probably wasn't the best at it but also
it's taking up all my time now I give it
to charity's we're vulnerable people can
take those houses and call them home but
I can go and look for more properties
and make good money so question for you
best deal on easier deals what kind of
give me a case today of one of these
service accommodation properties that
you've you've purchased I know you don't
usually use your own money still no I
well I don't I mean in all the years
I've been doing property I put the first
amount thirty six thousand pounds thirty
eight thousand pounds into my first ever
deal last year so I just get used to it
don't you you get used to what you what
would you use your own money if you can
use other people well if I told you that
my minimum ROI on an HMO is four hundred
and forty four percent that's just
ridiculous so why would I do it a
different way so you want an example
yeah so my first large one was a
run-down pub the lady was about to be
repossessed it was on the market for
nine hundred and fifty thousand
apparently but when I found it was on
for eight hundred and seventy five I
offered an option and they turned it
down
Anisha eventually I then offered
actually a catch put a cash purchase for
much less which they said yes to but
reneged on it was over a bank holiday
weekend and they accepted an extra three
thousand pounds believe it or not
however I did understand because the
agent I was using was charging far more
and every penny count it later on they
came back to me and they said we're
desperate the buyers pulled out and I
said look I can do this but I've just
spent the six hundred thousand I offered
you on another property investors money
of course I can do
but it's going to be for far less and it
will still have to be an option so we
did it as an option for far less I got
it for 495,000 as an eight month option
I allowed her to live in the property
until no not the obligations should not
the obligations so I got planning
permission right to turn it into a guest
house full planning permission and in
June Soria in March she moved out so we
could gut the place this was October
says she have another six months in
there in June we started and by
September the first it was ready and we
did cost of a million pounds refurb of
investors money yeah okay three years
later we financed and pulled every penny
out I didn't put one cent into it and
how much is that making you each month
now it depends it varies so I generated
usually I generate what is called four
million in revenue property what about
profit profit you're looking at probably
120 still very very good salary for one
deal it is so you know I move your own
money and then 120 a year those
how do you manage to get investors to
give you a quarter of a million it was
more than a quarter of a million because
it costs four hundred ninety five how do
you go we're then getting quarter of a
minute to do it so is eight hundred
thousand well on that particular option
stroke purchase in the end it was a
webinar and we got sixteen people to
give fifty grand with 50 grand no they
didn't need a charge on the property and
it you know for the poor solicitor it
was a little bit of a headache but you
know again it's a webinar weapon and
then you just said to people hey if
you're interested in doing a joint
venture with me or just to get some
guaranteed returns I didn't do the
weapon on that event my JV partner did
who I've now bought out right the next
one I did that was really big wasn't an
option it was done on a delayed
completion
yeah so investor money seventy six
thousand five hundred
it was sorry 76574
and then what we did was we did one
hundred
seventy thousand pound renovation yeah
but managed to get the bank and they've
never done this before to agree to give
a seventy five percent of the new value
having had the renovation done
incredible so we didn't have to
refinance six months later at that point
at 1.1 million nearly pulling all the
money out certainly pulling half of the
investor money out which we weren't
expecting to do not one single penny of
my money so it's all about being
creative these deals are obviously
incredible I'm always slightly envious
of some of these some of some of these
deals but hey we're working on some
exciting stuff to do what would you say
to someone who's watching this who's
kind of just starting out maybe they
don't own any houses yet or maybe they
just had a couple and they're thinking
wow like all this money and raising all
this finance and service combination
what would you say are the best starting
points first few stepping stones to
someone that's really just wanting to
grab this with two hands and go for it
well I'm a little bit different to other
people and I don't believe personally
that you need to start very small I I
wouldn't start with buy two less because
all they're going to where's the exit
strategy
hmo's is what rocks your boat you've got
to be able to find passion in it this
isn't just about money you've got to
enjoy you've got to have fun and if you
don't have fun it'll be jolly hard when
there are tough times and there will be
I think that you know if they want to do
I believe there's ways of doing things
without risk people might turn their
noses up at that and say it's not
there's not but there is it's a question
of how you structure it if you're not
putting any money into a deal and you've
got somebody else paying the interest to
the investor who's putting all the money
in the deal where's your risk yeah you
know so it's all about structure it's
about creativity you need to make sure
that you're listening to the right
people yeah a very good writer and
speaker called Joyce Meyer wrote a book
called approval addiction and in it she
says make sure that you put people
around you that do you good and not harm
you've got to do your due diligence in
every area you can take it and grab it
with both hands but you've got to make
sure that you're doing what you enjoy if
you decide to do something that
everybody else is doing it will take you
six months to work out you're not having
fun yeah so just be very careful and
sure of what you want before you start
that's incredible so do have good due
diligence ok good people around you that
can help you and support you and also
make sure that you risk assess what
you're doing absolutely on a property
front so now you've got as I said a
large portfolio of properties
financially free what are you wanting to
do property wise what are you plans
property wise in the future I keep
saying that it's my last project because
you know what some people want more and
more and more I don't actually need more
but I keep finding another project but I
like to do so right now I've just taken
I've just offered and had accepted an
option on a piece of land where I'm
building to eke a eek-eek Oh houses
right opposite my house actually but my
my plan really is I my favorite course
I'm running is an Alpine course in the
mountains which runs from my chalet in
the French Alps where we do half day
skiing half day learning in the summer
we do half day of extreme sports like
cascading down waterfalls and then we
come back and do half day of learning
and I find that it's so wonderful to see
the impact it has on people to actually
be sociable and living together like
that being scared on the slopes if
you've not skied before so you come back
and go I'm gonna do anything now Poppy's
a doddle but it because it's so much
about mindset yeah and I've had people
on those courses who have been doing
property for 12 years but in four and a
half days have monumental mindset shifts
mindset it's 80 percent person isn't it
I think that's why you spend so much
time inspiring people having them think
about their purpose I mean how's it
going today you do some stuff with that
guys today how's that going well I think
they're liking it but I'm loving it
they're loving it I'm absolutely I mean
because my heart is to teach yeah
many people good speakers but there's a
very big difference between a speaker
and a teacher when people say that oh oh
if you do so well in property then why
didn't you teach money I think that's
very very silly really because because
when you've got all the money you want
and when you've got all the properties
you want then what are you gonna do to
say I beat you do nothing it's it's each
to his own and for me let me just
correct you one little bit I'm not I
haven't got all the money I want I mean
when does that it's not
it's not enough it's just that
circumstances change but the point is
it's about having I always say we don't
have to be in control but we don't want
to be controlled and in a world of
people we've got to get back there's a
very big difference between those two
things and so I'm feeling that I'm
perfectly in control but I don't because
I'm not being controlled but I but I
don't mind if I don't always have
everything that I need it's not about
that you know we we we will I have a
very strong faith so I believe I'll get
everything I need because I've been
watched by wonderful Father in heaven in
terms of my my wanting that's very very
different but I want for very little
because my absolute passion is to edify
build up and help people yeah and so if
I can do that through teaching I don't
mind if I have a paper bag over my head
and I have a pseudonym yeah it's been so
good having you here so far I know
you've got people waiting but I just
wanted to ask you a question number one
what's been your biggest mistake and
what's been the lesson from that so you
can start first okay so my biggest
mistake was a few years ago I was doing
an option and I found a fantastic guest
house in Wantage and I had we'd agreed
the option and it was all going ahead
and the solicitors were putting all the
paperwork together
and I said we were the idea was
returning it from a former 7 bed guest
house to an 11 because upstairs they had
owners accommodation and all I had to do
was put shower rooms in so I had said
just very gently and without realizing
the implications oh I've got an lol l
npg account you can use that because
we'll get a greater discount yeah so
they used my LMG l npg account to get
their bathrooms and what have you got
them pulled the plug because the
contract hadn't been signed oh and
because it was in my name I had to pay
for them that was 16 grounds worth of
bathrooms that I never saw annoying and
that's not good so what did you learn
what I learned from it was I could
loathe the woman for a few days
but actually forgiveness is powerful
yeah unforgiveness eats you up oh yeah
but also you can either look at mistakes
and feel hopeless yeah or you can learn
from them and the blessing it's been for
me in helping people not to make that
mistake but also to challenge myself to
double what I lost in terms of revenue
within the next year was the way that
Julie Barlow works that's incredible
okay next question thank you for that
biggest success and lessons and
inspiration from to the listeners I
think the biggest success for me has
been understanding mindset yeah I tell
you that in my very first year of doing
property I did very little for six
months and I was so belligerent I can't
tell you I'd go but I did what I was
told but I didn't do it with the right
attitude and I had to change my mindset
and make that decision
in a split second to make the difference
and although that sounds like a
potentially weak success no it was what
made my success and the journey that
followed I love that Jilly thank you so
much for coming on the show let's go
back in the main room follow with the
students high five you're amazing thank
you thank you so much for watching if
you benefited from that video please do
share it with your family and friends
for more videos like it you can watch
right here and if you'd like to spend
two days with me at the property
investors crash course watch this video
see what happens but whatever you do
don't forget to subscribe right here and
I'll see you next time